so what is su blood well not according  to Lee nee what is some kind of ink lady  sent samples to the lab but one thing  that we do know is based on the writing  there's no way that Gabriel did this to  himself  so then someone at the hospital yeah I  called and they said that he didn't have  any writing on him when he escaped this  morning the Roman numerals are Bible  verses no words are all in Latin protect  me O Lord from the hands of the wicked  it's a prayer for salvation sounds like  he was scared but of what the mysteries  don't stop there  and I conducted the autopsy I found that  the wound had been inflicted by some  kind of talent or claw  like an animal it gets even weirder  there was a strange substance inside the  wound let me guess  sulfur yeah how'd you know guys isn't it  obvious  Latin prayers a claw sulfur also known  as brimstone you don't think that Oh  what I do you all have our demons  Gabriel was killed by his  you